I want to go OUTFRONT now
to John Sullivan, who was the US
ambassador to Russia
under President
Biden and former President Trump
and retired
Lieutenant General Mark Hertling
who was the Army
commanding general for Europe
and the Seventh Army.
I appreciate both of you
being with me so much.
Ambassador Sullivan,
I just want to start with you.
You heard Will Ripley is reporti
and now we're learning
Putin will not hold
his end of your press conference
which is an annual thing he has
He's also
taking questions from the Russia
during that time.
It is the first time since 2013
that he isn't going to do this.
So in almost ten years,
we're just looking at a
few of them on the screen here.
It is an annual tradition.
Ambassador, what is the signific
Putin skipping it this year?
Well, thanks, Erin.
It's very good to be with you.
I think
it's a sign of concern
about his domestic support.
I'd rather
we allow Victor Boot
and have Boot
recite the script that he just
we saw the video of him speaking
If you think that those words
were his words originally.
You're sadly mistaken.
That's the Kremlin speaking thro
He's useful to them as a mouthpi
Putin doesn't want to go out
and spend hours before
journalists, even state media, a
getting asked difficult
and embarrassing questions.
Ambassador,
there has been so much speculati
about Putin's health.
We've all seen it.
It's impossible to confirm it.
It's why we don't talk about it
But you've been in the room with
as recently as last year.
More recently than pretty much a
So what, if any, changes
do you see in him since then
and over the time you knew him?
When you look at all these repor
and you see him out there,
what do you see?
Well, thanks, Darren.
First of all,
when I've been with him in perso
he has looked the picture of hea
And that's certainly the assessm
There is no assessment by the U.
government that he is
has serious health problems.
You've heard my former colleague
CIA Director Bill Byrne,
say the problem with Putin's hea
is that it's too good
What I've witnessed,
however, in Moscow over the last
since this so-called special
military operation
began, is that Putin does look s
puffy over, tired
sort of the way I look now after
been through a war myself
there behind enemy lines in Mosc
I get it.
It's a lot of stress.
And I think that's what he's fee
We don't believe the United Stat
doesn't believe, as director Bur
that he's he's
got some serious medical issue
that is going to
take him out of the picture.
No, no, certainly not in the.
But I do find it interesting
what you're saying.
You're not buying
into any of those theories
and they're all out there.
I don't want to repeat them all.
But but you are.
To you, it does seem fair that
that he does look tired.
And I mean the word puffy
because it does feel accurate.
Some of those pictures
where people go into other theor
he seems puffy
in absolutely.
And there are times
when I think
when his rhetoric
sometimes gets ahead of him
and where he wants to go.
And I think that's a sign of of
He he really wants to be a perso
who is in control
very carefully modulated.
And there have been occasions
when his rhetoric
has gotten a little out front.
And I think that's
just a sign of fatigue,
which is understandable
given the stress that the man is
with the catastrophic blunder
he made by starting this
this war on the European control
I wanted to share
some new
video for for you
all and everyone
watching of what
appears to be a Russian combat
training instructor
for the 247th Regiment and Strav
pleading to a regional governor
pleading for more equipment and
Let me play it right
Your fighters that you sent to u
in Stavropol
Krai are almost completely naked
They have no medical kits
and they have just one ticket.
Any one of you come over here.
As you can see,
they have almost no protection.
And just to place you,
they don't have any thermal unde
The boys are freezing
Now, General,
we can't afford to get this vide
but I just will be clear.
It is in line
with previous reports,
videos, phone calls, of Russian
complaining about unbelievably i
and unacceptable supply situatio
for a modern military.
So is this
part of what we're seeing right
Is there any way for Russian for
to succeed on the ground
with the conditions that
we just heard outlined there?
Short answer, Erin.
No, absolutely not.
Here's here's what you have to c
Those new trainer trainees
that are coming in
after being mobilized
are prepared to be trained.
They're also prepared to be equi
That's individual training.
They teach them things
like rifle marksmanship
and first aid
and how to move in
small units and things like that
But that's just the first step.
And that takes weeks after that.
It takes months
to have them learn
what's called combined arms
operations, tanks, working with
working with armor,
working with engineers,
It literally takes months of tra
There was a Natal report submitt
that said the earliest,
if everything goes right,
that Russia can get mobilized
troops on the front lines is May
That's months away and that's co
Considering that they had everyt
they need.
The fact that those soldiers don
even have tourniquets Band-Aids.
I mean,
you showed a neurosurgeon in Ukr
operating on a brain the other n
in a combat support hospital.
These guys don't even have tourn
to wear on their uniforms.
So that means
they probably don't have medics.
They don't have first aid statio
They don't have support hospital
All of those.
All of those things contribute
to making a modern army.
And Russia continues to fail mis
Which is, you know,
we saw for the first time
some in state media asking him a
the shortages on the front lines
Who who do we believe them are y
And he says you don't believe an
but me.
And General Hertling,
to that point
and to the ambassador's
point about boot being the mouth
I wanted to share some new video
for you all
and everyone
watching of what
appears to be a Russian combat
training instructor
for the 247th Regiment and Strav
pleading to a regional governor
pleading for more equipment and
Let me play it
slightly for your fighters
that you sent to us here in Stav
Krai are almost completely naked
They have no medical kits
and they have just one tournique
Any one of you come over here.
As you can see,
they have almost no protection
and just two plates.
They don't have any thermal unde
The boys are freezing
Now, General,
we can't afford to get this vide
but I just will be clear.
It is in line
with previous
reports, videos,
phone calls of Russian troops
complaining about unbelievably i
and unacceptable supply situatio
for a modern military.
So is this part
of what we're seeing right now?
Is there any way for Russian for
to succeed
on the ground
with the conditions that we just
outlined there?
Short answer, Erin.
No, absolutely not.
Here's here's what you have to c
Those new trainer trainees
that are coming in
after being mobilized
are prepared to be trained.
They're also prepared to be equi
That's the individual training.
They teach them things
like rifle marksmanship
and first aid
and how to move in
small units and things like that
But that's just the first step.
And that takes weeks after that.
It takes months
to have them learn
what's called combined arms
operations, tanks,
working with infantry,
working with armor,
working with engineers.
It literally takes months of tra
There was a Natal report submitt
that said the earliest,
if everything goes right,
that Russia can get mobilized.
Troops on the front lines is May
That's months away and that's co
Considering that they had everyt
they need.
The fact that those soldiers
don't even have tourniquets, Ban
I mean,
you showed a neurosurgeon in Ukr
operating on a brain the other n
in a combat support hospital.
These guys don't even have tourn
to wear on their uniforms.
So that means
they probably don't have medics.
They don't have first aid statio
They don't have support hospital
All of those.
All of those things contribute
to making a modern army.
And Russia continues to fail mis
And I'm actually
having a flashback to about a ye
when we started reporting
for the first time on how
they were accumulating blood sup
on the front line.
Well, it looks like maybe they d
but they didn't do anything else